[Music]
my son scolds me mommy not having
only out there
I say he's going friends and I'm no longer afraid
a good little a squatter from Guayabero
[Music]
my name is María de los Santos Cáceres
almost
I was a wholesaler in cargo I called  cassava
yam
and now how to get displaced it's not I
feel good that sometimes I'm
poor forever it
's sometimes we go to bed without dinner without eating
because there's nothing to eat and that has
given me such a hard castle the
whole situation of  We, the
displaced, the
hard, what is
it?  sons killed dad I
find my son and he told me mommy
these papers were taken by two motorbikes there they
sent to vacate the pump
well let's go let's go that's where
people come with a lot of head let's go
so I went out crying  I'm from Wyoming or I was
n't born to live in town
I dream a lot with her in the bonga that
I'm going to live there again
no no
no no no
[Music]
this was the first house in the bonga
there was one
there there was another
here  there was one
and this was a hamlet that had two
streets two day streets the bonga and the
houses were located and here was one
there was another
it doesn't matter if it has light it doesn't matter if it
has cold water or television but I
am happy in the mouth
[  Music]
I want to live there in the bonga that
is as long as
40 percent of the population tells you that they
think differently and I think that will be the
challenge of the next president
in the soccer world championship but
there is enough to fulfill that
duty and with  that right,
what will happen if luque
wins, duke we are a bit confused
although he goes with those who have companies
with the rich and the peace contract would end on the
one hand it would harm us
because we could not return to the wave
and it will be that today  They are all going to vote
yes I think so because last time there
were the few who went
[Music]
and
without having any
at the finish line
[Music]
on the day the authorities reported
total normality throughout the country are the
calmest elections in the history
of cordial
colombia one side decided that márquez
was elected as the country's new president he
will be the youngest president
colombia has ever had more than 19
million colombians went into the shadows
space to continue encouraging
confrontations and ruptures here  It's no
longer about autism, depetrismo, it
's about Colombia
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope we have certain death,
we don't want to get there
and
[Music]
look at
and
[Music]